welcome back to 8701
so in this lecture and also the next we
want to look at some of the experimental
findings of neutrinos
given the sheer number of experiments
and the long history in which we are
trying to
understand neutrinos and neutrinos
behavior
um this can be rather confusing so i'm
trying to condense this
um a little bit and just give you the
highlights of the basic pieces of
information
so this one here shows a summary of what
we know from neutrino oscillation so if
we look at a
atmospheric neutrinos we find that
neural neutrinos and antimural neutrinos
disappear
and they're most likely converting into
town adrenals and antitonatroners
we look at accelerated neurons here we
are using
neural neurinas and antimurans we can
show that they disappear over distances
of 200 to 800 kilometers
from accelerators we also know that
they appear or reappear as electron or
anti-electron neutrinos over those
same distinctives from the solar
neutrinos
we know that electron neutrinos convert
into more neutrinos
and or tower neutrinos
there is more detail to the story that
i'm giving you here where we
uh would have to discuss the interaction
of the meta effects
of neutrinos that is for a different
lecture that goes beyond the scope of
what i want to discuss here
from reactor neutrinos we also know that
anti-electron neutrinos disappear
as well so the name of the game now is
to
you know take all of those pieces of
information
and extract information about the
neutrinos property
and that in order to do that
one has to make assumption about the
number of available neutrino generations
and in some parts of the interpretation
also about the nature of the nurturing
um
as you know you can simply figure out of
the exercise we had before
it matters to the neutrino oscillation
probabilities whether or not one assumes
two or three or four neutrinos
in the mix but if you just focus here on
three neutrinos
um we still have the problem that we
we have the generous degeneracies in
in the discussion um and they can be uh
boiled down to two major kind of trends
one is where the spectrum of the
neutrino masses
follows a normal ordering meaning that
the mass of the first
smaller than the mass of the second is
smaller than the mass of the third
or that the spectrum is inverted
meaning that the mass of the third might
be smaller than the mass of the second
in the mass of this first and the second
data suggests that the difference in
mass
the difference squared in mass mass
splittings between those states
is such that delta m one two squared is
much much smaller
than delta m one three one three one
squared which is approximately the same
size of delta m
three two squared so if we look now at
the numbers
for the normal hierarchy spectrum um we
find that the mass of the first is much
much smaller than the mass of the second
which is a little bit smaller than the
mass of this third numerically we find
the mass of the second is in the order
of
eight times ten to the minus three
electron volt in the mass of the third
in the order of 0.05 electron volts
so really really small masses
um the inverted spectrum here the story
is slightly different here we find that
m1 is about 0.05 electron volts
which is similar to the square root of
the mass splitting between
three and two which is also 0.05
electron volts
the information of the neutrino
oscillation experiment and then
how to the map into the individual
parameters
of our neutrino ckm matrix is summarized
here and also in the mass information
um and i don't want to read the entire
lab table i just leave this
here for you so in order to understand
this one has to
go back to the first slide and
understand what kind of information we
extract from the third from from various
neutrino experiments for example the
solar and natural experiments
and then think about is this sensitive
to
uh oscillations between the first and
the second generation
or the first in the third generation
generation
so that's kind of the the mapping you
have to do in order to understand this
table fully
some experiment where the information
just dominates the position of certain
measurements and others as combinations
of results coming out
the the other reason why i put this
table here
in this in this in this lecture is to
just illustrate
how diverse the landscape of experiments
is
and why that's needed in order to get a
full picture of neutrinos and their
properties
one has to identify the individual
properties
in the experiments and then put the
picture back together
in global fits or in a general analysis
of the data